aussi cette affaire qui a dont tout le
monde a parlé on va revenir sur une
vidéo qui a fait le tour des réseaux
sociaux ces derniers jours dans cette
vidéo on voit une maman une maman
frapper et humilie un odolé un
adolescent elle l'accuse d'avoir frappé
son fils alors on va regarder cette
vidéo et juste après la maman de
l'adolescent victime de cette simulation
humiliation sera avec nous c'est
vraiment une exclusivité la vidéo vous
allez voir elle est incroyable moi je
croyais que c'était au début je croyais
que c'était un prank je vous jure que
c'est vrai la mère de famille commence
par insulter l'adolescent puis une
première gifle arrive rapidement
regardez le début chez nous
il a tu crois que tu vas grimper qui non
monsieur chez ta mère je vais t'enculer
ta mère
merci d'être avec nous merci
vous êtes alors on m'a pas on m'a pas
mis votre prénom
Nathalie merci Nathalie d'être là vous
êtes la maman de la victime c'est un
truc de fou je vous dis tout le monde a
vu la vidéo quand vous avez dû voir la
vidéo vous avez dû être
bouleversé
vous avez dû avoir une rage folle vous
êtes encore voilà sous le choc de ce
qu'on voit et minisia est avec nous vous
êtes amis de la famille de la victime
merci d'être là également on va on va
voir la vidéo parce que vous l'avez pas
tous eu elle ordonne ensuite à votre
fils au jeune garçon de se mettre à
genoux tout en continuant à l'insulter
elle lui demande de s'excuser auprès de
son fils
dans ta gueule
sur la tête regarde-moi bien c'est lui
qui touche à l'école
c'est la vidéo de du week-end c'est
incroyable vous allez voir la suite dans
un instant mais Nathalie vous étiez bien
sûr pas présente lors de cette
altercation comme vous avez été mise au
courant
c'est ma fille qui m'a mise au courant
parce qu'en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est que la maman elle s'est présentée
devant mon immeuble d'accord et en fait
à l'interphoné et
j'attendais mon fils comme il rentrait
de cours et du coup je suis descendue et
j'ai parlé avec la maman
elle m'a dit votre fils a tapé à griffer
mon fils donc j'ai dit à mon fils de
s'excuser auprès de l'enfer
c'est vrai cette histoire il y a une
altercation entre les deux avant
c'est pas vraiment enfin j'appellerai
pas ça une interse
en fait c'est parce que son fils a
attrapé le col de mon fils de mon fils
du coup il a étranglé donc en fait mon
fils pour se défendre en fait c'est
juste défendu en mettant sa main et en
fait à ce moment là il a griffé le
visage de l'enfant d'accord et c'est ça
et en fait la maman en allant chercher
son fils
elle a vu coiffure sur le visage de son
fils et c'est comme ça qu'elle est
calée venue elle est venue donc elle
vient en bas de chez vous elle vous dit
quoi vous dit non mais elle m'a juste
dit voilà que voilà qu'elle voulait
régler des choses en interne avant ça
c'était après d'accord donc moi j'ai
rien sur
elle était très calme ah d'accord on
s'est parlé enfin comme je vous parle
vraiment juste après ça c'était juste
après ça et moi je l'ai suis après parce
que ma fille m'a appelée et elle me dit
maman comment il va est-ce que tout
est-ce que ce qu'il est rentré à la
maison donc je lui dis oui mais je
comprends pas et elle me dit oui mais
parce qu'il y a tout le monde qui est
venu me voir qui m'envoie des messages
des vocaux et je fais je comprends pas
et elle vous en a pas parlé et elle me
dit oui et il m'explique mais je
comprends pas si ce qu'il me dit et
[Musique]
vraiment je mon cerveau il s'est arrêté
je il m'expliquait il m'expliquait je
comprenais pas et au moment où j'ai
commencé à
à prendre conscience de ce qui me disait
je lui dis mais en fait tu peux pas
accuser une mère comme ça et j'ai pris
la défense de la mer à la limite mais
oui parce que pour moi enfin jamais je
me permettrais de réagir comme elle a
fait à la limite gronder l'enfant et de
voir ce qui s'est passé de demander les
deux versions mais à aucun moment
j'aurais réagi comme mal à réagi parce
qu'elle va pas s'arrêter là parce
qu'elle va ensuite menacer de façon très
ribérulente le jeune garçon ainsi que
tous les autres spectateurs de cette
scène regarde
tu dois passer tout le monde on m'a dit
à l'école elle est où la fille qui l'a
giflé
des paroles là
ton nom je viens je te traîne sur le sol
jusqu'à chez toi tu as compris jusqu'en
bas de chez toi bien entendu et demain
tu es dans le bureau de la proviseur
vous allez voir la suite de la vidéo
dans un instant vous pouvez même pas
regarder la vidéo ça y est je l'ai vu en
fait je l'ai vu une fois et c'est bon
c'est vrai que quand elle dit que elle
dit un moment elle dit votre fils
tape un peu tout le monde à l'école
est-ce que c'est vrai ou est-ce que
c'est pas du tout vrai c'est pas du tout
vrai
qui connaissez bien la famille son fils
que je connais très bien il est pas du
tout dans les histoires c'est une
famille qui est super discrète et il est
pas du tout dans l'harcèlement et c'est
important de ne pas échanger les rôles
parce que quand la vidéo a vécu sur les
réseaux sociaux il y en a beaucoup qui
me dit oui mais le petit harceler donc
du coup moi j'aurais réagis pareil en
tant que maman c'est pas vrai
au contraire c'est son fils qui fait un
peu tout le monde au collège un peu une
terreur faut le dire après vu la maman
on comprend pourquoi pas c'est lui qui
c'est c'est l'office c'est l'office de
cette dame qui embaude qui embêtait
votre fils à la base en fait c'est ça
donc
il a pris au col et votre fils il a
d'ailleurs quand ça s'est passé mon fils
après il s'est écarté de lui c'est
écarté d'accord parce que pour pas avoir
d'histoire et il le sait enfin nous à la
maison moi j'ai toujours dit je veux pas
d'histoires je voilà tu te tiens tu es à
l'école c'est pour travailler c'est pas
pour voilà et le sait alors justement je
voudrais parler de votre site mais
qu'est-ce qui vous a dit à un moment
qu'est-ce qui vous a dit est-ce que vous
a dit c'est ce qui vous a raconté la
scène est-ce que vous a dit maman ça a
été un moment très compliqué très dur je
vois plus retourner à l'école par
exemple il voulait retourner à l'école
ah oui il y avait des évaluation il a
voulu y retourner il vous dit quoi
aujourd'hui moralement il va comment ben
là il montre que ça va mais il y a des
moments où je connais mon fils je sais
qu'il y a que ça le touche mais le dira
pas oui s'exprime autrement puisqu'il
vous dit bah il me dit par exemple
bah maman je trouve que les réseaux
Internet où ça c'est bien mais d'un
autre côté c'est pas bien donc je lui
demande pourquoi je lui demande
pas de problème
c'est ce qui m'a dit il a été rajeunu
bien sûr et du coup il a été très
content dans le sens où on a pu voir la
vérité qui en fait ce qu'il disait
c'était la vérité même si j'ai pas pu le
croire
je me suis excusée aussi le soir même
auprès de mon fils je l'ai serré fort
dans mes bras je me suis excusée et je
lui enfin je lui ai fait comprendre que
enfin pour moi c'était inacceptable et
que c'était même inhumain enfin jamais
enfin moi personnellement c'est pour ça
que j'ai défendu la dame en fait elle
était là quand je l'ai défend son fils
ou pas du tout ah pas du tout pas du
tout mais c'était elle nous disait que
c'était une terreur dans le dans l'école
est-ce que c'est vrai ou pas c'est une
petite ville donc tout le monde se
connaît c'est vraiment le collège du
quartier donc on a tous été là-bas et
donc petit frère ils sont aussi là-bas
donc on sait comment ça se passe et on
connaît à peu près les profils et lui
c'est toi c'est assez un profil ah oui
ah oui
il m'embête à l'école et là j'ai essayé
de me défendre une fois c'était là la
seule fois et la seule fois qu'est-ce
qui lui avait fait qu'est-ce qui est
pourquoi il a étranglé au départ à la
base il est arrivé en fait il a
il y avait la journée sportive donc il y
a un camarade à lui qui l'a interpelle
donc il se dirige vers cette ce camarade
sauf que ce garçon-là était à côté et il
lui dit laisse le moi
je vais me le faire ou je vais me le
prendre et à ce moment-là où il a voulu
l'étrangler enfin prendre par le col et
en fait mon
fils il a juste s'enlever en fait et en
fait au moment où il s'est envie la
griffer et ça s'est arrêté là après il
s'est déplacé il s'est mis devant pour
pas être à côté de lui qu'est-ce que
quand vous avez vu la vidéo
vous avez ressenti quoi
la première vidéo que moi j'ai vu
c'était
où il était déjà genoux d'accord voilà
donc moi ayant eu la discussion avec
elle juste avant
je suis restée choquée bien sûr que même
par rapport aux propos
on est vraiment quand je vous dis elle
parlait calmement c'est vraiment on a
une discussion entre enfin comme vous et
moi à aucun moment je me serais doutée
qu'elle aurait fait ce genre de choses
envers mon fils je parle voilà je me dis
c'est vrai que moi je vois ça c'est vrai
qu'à un moment je me dis je vais là je
vais aller la retrouver qu'est-ce que
vous êtes dit
est-ce que c'est pas ce qu'il faut faire
en fait je suis resté en fait choqué en
fait je suis dans l'incompréhension je
comprends pas comment une mère puisse
réagir ainsi elle me dit
on va je voulais m'expliquer avec vous
avant d'aller voir le collège ce que je
trouve ça honorable parce que j'aurais
fait la même chose demandez à avoir les
parents d'avoir une discussion de voir
les versions qui se sont dites entre qui
sont qui ont été faites selon les
enfants voilà après s'il y a besoin mais
c'est ce que je dis je lui dis mais s'il
y avait besoin d'aller voir le collège
si mon fils avait fait quoi que ce soit
qu'il assume les conséquences s'il doit
être qu'il y a une heure de colle ou une
autre sanction il aurait assumé
est-ce que le fils de cette dame est à
l'école actuellement
est-ce qu'elle a essayé de vous
rejoindre après ou pas du tout ce
qu'elle était en garde à vue là
le 22 décembre
50 prisons 150000 euros d'amende Pascal
non seulement des violences sur mineur
de moins de 15 ans mais le Daily le plus
grave c'est provocation directe d'un
mineur à commettre un délit en
l'occurrence son fils elle incite à
taper et c'est ça c'est 50 prisons alors
ancienne cette dame une dame finit par
arriver pour essayer de calmer la la
maman mais s'il est bien il fait un
verre ce qui se produit regardez le
s'énerve davantage et menace cette dame
à son tour regardez
qu'est-ce qui se passe tu as entendu
lâche-moi occupe des affaires là
[Musique]
c'est malheureux parce que à ça qui fait
ça en fait ça le problème c'est à dire
oui c'est
personnellement ce serait moi qui aura
intervenu à moi pas parler comme ça ah
oui ah oui pourquoi
c'est trop facile de s'attaquer au plus
faible qui sont vulnérables personne qui
n'ont pas forcément le courage d'aller à
la front mais moi ce serait pas passé
comme ça quand vous voyez ça je vous
sens très énervé mais moi ça me vénère
en fait ça m'énerve c'est du gratuit
surtout que je connais le petit il est
toujours gentil et tout calme on a vu
ensuite des bandes de jeunes à les
rechercher la mer avec des bâtons etc
c'est quoi la réaction ils sont fâchés
après attention on incite pas à la
violence
elle laisse la justice à quelque chose
avec pas non plus que ça retourne contre
eux mais c'est normal que les réactions
elles sont à chaud comme ça et c'est
pour ça aussi que que je voulais venir
même si je suis pas du tout à l'aise
merci d'être là
pour moi ça me paraissait important
aussi déjà de remercier tout le monde
mais vraiment tout le monde qui nous
soutiennent et qui sont derrière nous et
merci encore à toi mais voilà c'est
important aussi de le dire
mais aussi voilà on compte un peu aussi
sur la justice
parce que pas laisser ça un puni
justement quand vous entendez 5 ans
d'emprisonnement
voilà quel coach qui a 5 ans
d'emprisonnement si demain la justice en
quelques quelques mois dit elle va elle
a 5 ans d'emprise comment
personnellement je veux que voilà que
que qu'elle soit punie pour ce qu'elle a
fait après le nombre d'années ça sera
jamais à l'auteur de ce qu'elle a fait
mon fils pensez jamais
votre fille
en fait ça sera jamais à la hauteur de
ce qu'elle a fait vous sentez qu'il y a
un changement depuis dans son
comportement qu'il est son comportement
quand même
et ouais il va pas être comme avant le
cache il est il cache il est
il a quel âge il a 10 ans il a 10 ans
donc aujourd'hui il est comment il est
il a 10 ans bah là il fait sa petite vie
de collégien il veut aller à l'école il
va aller à l'école parce que voilà il
sait que pour nous ce qui l'embête aussi
c'est que il dit c'est c'est chiant les
réseaux parce que tout le monde a vu
cette vidéo et j'ai un peu honte il faut
lui dire qu'il a pas avoir honte à lui
le pauvre Céline
quand j'ai parlé avec les jeunes quand
j'ai parlé avec les jeunes mais j'ai
expliqué et un des jeunes qui m'a dit
mais madame a ce qui retourne à l'école
je lui dis oui mais pourquoi il
retournerait pas et c'est de là où il me
dit mais en fait il a été humilié il est
humilié on va se moquer de lui mais j'ai
fumé même si les on se moque de lui là
il est déjà été humilié et je fais mais
c'est pas grave mon fils il va se
relever mais ne vous inquiétez même pas
pour ça il va se relever mon fils alors
on parlait de vengeance on va regarder
cette vidéo qui était qui est devenue
virale si vous nous rejoignez à 21h11
les jottes du quartier qui sont partis à
la recherche de cette maman regardez
[Rires]
[Musique]
racine des Alouettes
alors justement qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé le ministère qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé du coup
la vidéo vu que je l'ai partagée sur les
réseaux et j'en ai parlé la ville est en
colère les les jeunes étaient en colère
et donc du coup ils ont voulu faire se
faire justice soi-même
sont restées en fait en dessous du
bâtiment d'accord et donc il y a pas eu
d'altercation entre les jeunes et la
maman
donc c'est bien heureusement
heureusement parce que c'est vrai que ça
aurait pu se retourner contre eux et
alors que ça c'est vrai que on peut
comprendre leur colère mais c'est pas la
bonne solution parce que ça serait
retourné contre eux et contre votre fils
et et contre vous aujourd'hui je vous
sens extrêmement ému vraiment
on va devoir son enfant
frapper comme ça enfin c'est pas
possible
c'est pas possible c'est juste pas
possible et en plus c'est même pas le
sien enfin j'étais pas qu'il faut taper
son enfant mais c'est pas possible en
fait enfin on connaît pas l'enfant au
lieu de demander les explications on lui
demande rien là on le tape gratuitement
on lui dit devant tout le monde ça passe
sur tous les réseaux à la télé
mon fils il en pense quoi mais
heureusement qu'il a dit que tout le
monde est derrière lui que en fait il a
dû soutien même quand il allait il a été
à l'école on l'a accompagné il s'est
senti soutenu parce qu'il y avait tous
ses camarades qui lui ont demandé
comment ça va même les tous les élèves
de tous l'établissement lui demande
comment ça va et ça je trouve ça et je
lui ai dit mais c'est normal et quand il
m'a dit qu'il était choqué par cette
réaction là je lui dis mais c'est normal
parce que les gens sont humains et ce
qu'elle a fait c'est pas du tout normal
et elle va être punie pour ça et moi
j'ai une bonne question quand même qui
revient beaucoup et vous devez vous la
poser c'est pourquoi les gens sont
intervenus aussi tard on a l'impression
que c'est très très long et que personne
n'intervient il y a aucun adulte aucun
intervient je suis assez étonné
il y a pas d'adultes qui intervient
pendant pendant hyper longtemps
il y a pas du mouvement et
[Musique]
elle aurait peut-être pas réagi de la
même manière elle aurait peut-être pas
eu tous ses propos là
parce que mon fils il a que 10 ans mais
si il était beaucoup plus costaud je
sais pas si elle aurait réagit de la
même façon exactement voilà mon fils
était aussi qui a 11 ans a vu la vidéo
il savait que vous veniez ce soir il a
dit voilà de faire un gros bisou à votre
fils que il comprend qu'il faut pas
qu'ils soient et c'est vrai que voilà il
tous les tous les petits ont regardé
cette vidéo et surtout tous demander
comment on aurait réagi c'est vrai et
tout le monde dit ça et c'est vrai que
voilà et je trouve que votre fils en
plus
il a une réaction on voit que c'est
quelqu'un qui voilà c'est on voit que
c'est quelqu'un de bien voilà il il
aurait on voit qu'il obéit à l'autorité
tout de suite on voit que c'est pas
voilà je vous dis la vérité je vous jure
que c'est vrai moi voilà mon fils après
il est peut-être moins bien édiqué mais
il m'a dit voilà si ça avait été la même
chose ce serait mal terminé et c'est
vrai que moi je lui ai dit justement bah
lui il a eu la bonne réaction que toi tu
aurais pas eu voilà j'ai engueuler mon
fils à cause de à cause de non mais
c'est vrai je vous jure que c'est vrai
non mais je vous jure que c'est vrai je
vais essayer de vous détendre aussi un
peu mais je vous jure que c'est vrai
parce qu'on en a beaucoup parlé et on
était avec ses potes tout ça et voilà et
c'est vrai que votre fils a eu un
comportement incroyable et moi je pense
fort à lui et vous lui dites qu'au
contraire lui c'est lui le héros c'est
lui le héros c'est pas c'est pas elle
hein je vous le dis ok vous bravo pour
eux aussi votre avis merci à